you
/ dancing you are a member of the Nobel
Prize Committee for physics and I wonder
if you have talked to the Prize laureate
before the press conference yes so we we
called them up about 40 minutes ago we
reached both both of them and they were
of course very happy wait where were
they so Sara Raasch was out on the
street somewhere together with his wife
David Wineland we woke up in them it's
half past 4:00 in the morning so he was
asleep so what did they say well I think
they were both very happy and and both
of them expressed that they were very
happy to share the prize with the other
I just wonder both of them work in the
field of physics called quantum optics
which has been very active since 30
years ago like since 1980s and both have
worked in parallel did they work
together so they they work in slightly
different disciplines because they are
one is looking at photons like particles
and the other one is looking at ions but
they have their methods have very much
in common and and of course they know
each other from conferences etc so that
they are actually good friends this is a
very active field of research so what
did they do that the others did not so
they have managed to capture and control
quantum particles in a very precise way
so they for instance are or she is using
two mirrors to capture photons in
between the mirrors and then he's
sending in atoms between the mirrors
like
this to probe the probe the state of the
photons David Wineland is is doing a
little bit the opposite because he's
he's in still at creating a little trap
for ions and then he's shooting laser
light in to control the ions though to
control and to sort of measure the
system and the trick is to capture just
one particle one photo well yes can
either capture just one or a few or they
can and so on they have such good
control that they can sort of determine
how many particles they trap oh it's so
it's it's hard and it's also very hard
to keep them there so that they don't
fly away so you need enough time to
study these quantum particles it's not
just that you need the tools to be able
to measure you also need to have them
there for sufficiently long time so that
you can study time evolution of these
quantum particles at the press
conference you mentioned some key words
from quantum physics like superposition
than the coherence something about
superposition is the fact that a quantum
object can be in two states
simultaneously this is we call
superposition so for instance a particle
can be in two places at the same time
and it's not really until we measure it
that we sort of pin down in which of the
two places it is but there's equal there
can be an equal probability of being in
two places at the same time and then the
coherence is when coherence is when when
the quantum system loses this property
of being in a superposition it's like
being in two places at the same time or
like the shredding edge can't be
and and so that this in particular is
one of the things that has been studied
by the Lord's they have been able to
produce these kind of Schrodinger cat
states and they've been able to study
how it actually decays in time and and
what they find is that the decay is
faster the more different the two states
are and of course if you have like in
the Schrodinger's cat paradox where the
issue is whether a cat can be dead or
alive and they dead and alive at the
same time those two states are of course
very very different not only for the cat
owner but also for quantum physicists
and since they are so different that
state would decay in in an extremely
short time it's a little strange because
the decay must be the most common
phenomena in the world we'd never see it
and and it's precisely that all the
things we see happen after the
decoherence have taken place but if we
can look into the quantum world and look
at single particles then we can actually
investigate these properties of
superposition but in normal life they
have d cohered so we don't see it that
is dead or alive you mentioned an
application of these studies and quantum
physics like quantum computer is it much
better than the computers we have today
first of all one should say that it's
that's a very it's a it's a distant
dream and it will take a long time
before there's anything like a quantum
computer but what what especially
Wineland has done is to take one of the
very first steps to show that you can do
quantum operations on honest quantum
system
that's the first step to worship on a
computer what would the quantum computer
do that the computers cannot so there
are certain algorithms that the quantum
computer could do much much faster than
an ordinary computer and and that the
the prime example is to factor large
numbers into primes that would be that
yes that would be extremely much faster
with the quantum computer but future
will tell that I'm sure there will be
also a number of other things that can
can be useful on a quantum computer so
why don't we have it here now oh because
because this is very hard to do when you
see today we have awarded a Nobel Prize
to to these two guys who have taken the
first step to to have control on on a
single system but to make a quantum
computer you would have to have the same
amount of control on very many particles
at the same time it will not come next
year isn't about price I can almost
promise that